vous avez du talent vous rêvez de monter
sur scène est de devenir une star la
première organise le plus grand concours
de chant de tout l'outre-mer site rage
pour découvrir les meilleurs chanteurs
de martinique
zik revient jusqu'à vous pour cela on a
transformé des containers en studio
d'enregistrement mobile qui vont
circuler de commune en commune
pour participer c'est très simple quand
vous téléchargez l'appli vous chanter et
vous postez vous pouvez chanter ce que
vous voulez et en n'importe quelle
langue avec l'appli tout le monde peut
chanter mais tout le monde peut aussi
voter si vous êtes sélectionné on vous
ouvre les portes et vous pourrez changer
dans le trech et si vous gagnez vous
participerez en live à la finale de
martinique et peut-être à la grande
finale à paris
zik trucks et si c'était vous la plus
belle voix de martinique
[Musique]